[Musique]
son
traversart
cétait
Matern Contin CRÉO en française mais
trad
créoleit madame moit
[Musique]
non
le livre marche bien du coup nous l'a
dit ben nous va continuer nous va fait
un spectacle avec gros Babou en l'air
l'idée c'était de travailler un peu de
manière poétique un peu auirie comme ça
avec une identité créole quand même
soutenue par exemple au C de la lune mon
ami Pierro nous a dit dans la ligne fait
clair monallon zampul pour pouvoir rimer
avec pétrole on fait des interventions
je demande vous savez c'est où avignon
non et ben quand nous chante 20 décembre
dans chaudron à la place de sur sur le
pont d'Avignon et ben tu connais pas où
il est le chaudron mais mais du coup il
est pas
[Musique]
loin ça qui important c'est c'était
vraiment de partir de l'univers du livre
de se dire voilà ça c'est si un M un pou
pays donc on part de là et du coup
finalement qu'est-ce qui va se passer il
va se passer que les
personnages bon P ça bouge
[Musique]
partout nous ça va aussi dans les
quartiers avec le petit Babou en l'air
donc c'est des petites formules qui
permettent à nous d'aller dans les
médiathèques dans les dans les centres n
faire les crèches dans les écoles et
tout ça essaie de toucher le maximum de
de créoles ici après peut-être aller un
petit peu dans d'autres pays créol
Maurice des Antill tout ça pour partager
notre
expérience
pour